[Music]
it was an accident
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Sweet Caroline she's just seen what you
did back there it was awesome
first the string dress like whew then
the whole thing exploded like pew pew
pew Brown and you just call me walk
dabbed at all it was so badass it looks
like you're bleeding quite a bit though
but no need to worry my brother's coming
back soon and he can mix medicine
everything's gonna be all right you'll
see where am i this
it's our hideout you see nobody else
knows where it is
I'm super good at finding all the best
hideouts wait you were the one who
carried me here uh yeah my brother
helped a little oh thanks a lot kid
what's your name anyway
I'm fine I guess people call me that
because I'm little or something but it's
I like what you've got going on you
better watch out cuz I'm gonna put this
foot in your I meant
hi honey I'm Rhonda nice to meet you I'm
glad you're not dead but you must be
crazy coming into the tunnels like this
I mean everyone I know is trying to get
out of them seriously yeah well I really
couldn't find another way around it
there's someone I need to speak to on
the other side and I thought down here I
could lose the people chasing me
where's my bag bag you didn't have it
back damn there goes plan a Oh Ranjha
you need to get better first she's right
you know I don't know where you think
you gotta be but you are no shape to go
anywhere
that's your brother yeah my street
brother
Street families your only real family am
i right copper
yeah pine your only real family oh and
this fella here is thinking I rescued
him from a pack Raiders I've never seen
him this friendly way more than he is
with copper which suits me just fine
thank you
I keep telling you that thing needs
shots you probably do too hey feel free
to ignore him he's just afraid of
thinking hey what are you doing the
waters poison no water is just water
there's poison in the water but poison
can be removed and then some parts of
the poison be mixed with a few other
things and yeah suddenly you've got
something useful coppers the very best
doctor from miles around doctor he looks
like he's 12
I'm 13 Thank You girls just develop
faster than boys everybody knows that
okay I'm done let's see what we got here
wait this can't be from the crash looks
like a a knife cut it's cuz she's got
people chasing her copper by the way why
are people chasing him well it's because
I heard someone very important to me
important to a lot of people
[Music]
I can't stay here they'll be looking for
me
promise you'll be careful Rhonda the
Vandal Shepherd's temple is really close
behind if I have any hope of getting out
of here it's through them
[Music]
so tell me where is this temple huh Wow
yes crazy the fire first left second
left up the ladder right 200 steps find
the whole wall see you pipe copper thank
you
goodbye biggie today's like the coolest
person effort she's all right I guess
I wouldn't if I were you see yo we found
what an interesting day no as well dad
miss discípulos a new face in my tunnel
is always worth celebrating on the other
hand my last working cargo train was
destroyed today it's just a coincidence
I'm sure but that's the thing about
interesting it's a double-edged sword I
don't trust her
this one's too pretty and clean to be a
Raider what are you doing here I'm here
because I need to get to the other side
and we both know that the Vandal
Shepards control access to the tunnels
so I came here to pay tribute tribute
what tribute I lost it on the cargo
train
[Music]
you come into my family's temple without
tribute and then admit to destroying our
property why are you here wait my name
is Rhonda Vega I am the daughter of our
reveille go what an interesting day in
Dayton your father truly was a great man
the only one who could keep all of us
saw the gang's all burrows from tearing
each other apart
willing to sacrifice his own life in
order to keep the peace as a fellow
warrior I respect that
well he would say that killing me
instead of letting me pass a senseless
and he had no respect for fools
unfortunately if my Shepherds don't get
to see a sinners blood that's when
things really start to get senseless and
let's be honest we all know you've
sinned so it's time to confess it to my
waters but it was it was an accident
what did you do
what was it Rhonda tell me why it is
exactly that you deserve to die right
here and right now you will confess it
to my waters
it was me I killed him I killed my own
father somos nada sin familia
[Applause]
no easy matter
you don't even have a clue what's
happening to you do you you better run
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good knock first this is where she's
supposed to be right the goat who never
heard of her
only ladies that live around these parts
are my girls here
they say she knew my father no way so
that would make you Rhonda am i right
so she is here well she was here no one
ever knows when and where shelter enough
she's probably in one of her other spots
well do you know when that will be
hmm no way I don't know anything about
that I just take care of the girls here
but I heard she was headed across town
could try that way I might have some
luck what's luck oh no just something my
mom used to say
everybody wants something from the goat
what do you want Cheston answer about
what's happening to me
oh yeah the goat could tell you that for
sure come on Rhonda smile a little after
all there's an a better time to be alive
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]